[Applaudissements]
merci merci à tous merci Philippe et
n'oublions pas les réunions très
enrichissantes où il a fallu qu'on se
mette tous
d'accord parce qu'on a débattu très
profondément de l'ensemble de cette
problématique et j'ai voulu que la
question centrale de la défense soit
intégrée dans un projet
économique et l'ambition que nous avons
pour la défense ne met nullement en
cause les engagements qui ont été les
nôtres de réduction des dépenses
publiques par ailleurs et de baisse des
impôts vous avez bien compris que nous
sommes dans un ensemble
cohérent et c'est pour ça que nous avons
fait cher beaucoup de réunions et qu'à
l'arrivée nous pouvons présenter un
front uni ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'avant nous n'avons pas débattu avec
passion je veux donc remercier Philippe
Meunier je je le remercie de sa
compétence son dynamisme et de l'esprit
nouveau de synthèse qu'il a voulu qu'il
a bien
voulu
manifester c'est c'est c'est toute
l'affection immense que j'ai pour lui
mais ça été vraiment une découverte de
voir un Philippe qui n'a renoncé à rien
mais qui qui qui l'a fait dans un
ensemble harmonieux vraiment je suis
reconnaissant je vis remercier aussi y
Fromion dont l'engagement est est connu
de de longuees dates à qui je veux dire
mon amitié Philippe
Vitel et Olivier AIV Bertin qui sont
passionnés par la question militaire pas
simplement parce qu'ils sont des élus
DUV j'ai beaucoup aimé Olivier ce que tu
as dit je veux saluer Christophe koto a
qui je serai jeudi prochain qui est nos
experts sur toutes les questions
industrielles de défense Marianne Dubois
à qui j'envoie un salut très amical
Gérard Longuet qui fut un ministre de la
Défense excellent et j'ai été fier quand
tu travailles à mes
côtés vous savez ça fait plaisir d'avoir
des gens qui sont ministres et qui aime
les responsabilités qu'on leur
confie et alors
et par ailleurs et qui ne regrette pas
ses
responsabilités encore mon cher Gérard
encore tu es une espèce à toi tout seul
tout à fait étrange mais que j'apprécie
et je veux aussi saluer Jean-François
Lamour et bien sûr tous les les
intervenants
alors la situation est d'une
gravité assez exceptionnelle puisque la
France cumule les situations d'être à la
fois en état d'urgence et en état de
guerre je je ne polémique pas je je ne
je ne dramatise pas les mots ont un sens
la France est aujourd'hui en état
d'urgence et en état de guerre et
naturellement c'est cette
réalité qui nous a fait construire le
raisonnement de notre politique de
défense
nous nous trouvons
confrontés la France et l'Europe
naturellement à des menaces d'une
intensité d'une
diversité d'une
simultanéité je pense sans précédent
depuis la fin de guerre
froide je je n'ai pas le souvenir sauf à
me tromper d'avoir pu utiliser ces trois
mots simultanés diverses et intensité
pour pour caractériser la situation
d'aujourd'hui
elle est la conséquence d'abord d'une
erreur le nouvel ordre
mondial issu des années
90 avec toutes
cette
baliverne
intellectuelle sur la fin de
l'histoire cet ordre mondial qu'on nous
présentait comme définitif a été
remplacé par quoi par un des ordre
mondial la caractéristique de la
situation d'aujourd'hui c'est le
désordre et le désordre
mondial ce qu'on nous présentait comme
la fin de
l'histoire et naturellement on se
retrouve face à des menaces protif il y
a d'abord la menace
djihadiste lié pas simplement mais lié
au chaos Moyen-Orient en un an la France
a connu deux actes d'une exceptionnelle
gravité aux portes de l'Europe nous
avons une déstabilisation quasi complète
de tout le sud de la
Méditerranée mis à part le Maroc nous
pouvons nous
appuyer sur un grand roi
et souhaitons lui longue vie que nous
regardons la
situation pas simplement du Maghreb mais
du machreb
nous ne voyons
que destruction c'est la Syrie rayé de
la carte comme pays en
vérité déstabilisation de la
Libye cette Tunisie qui est si proche de
nous 780 km de distance entre Tunis et
Nice qui est dans une situation qui
devrait nécessiter un effort sans
précédent de notre part parce que la
sécurité en Tunisie c'est la sécurité en
France et je ne dirai rien de nos amis
algériens parce que je sais que le sujet
est
sensible mais c'est un sujet et j'
pososerai un démenti formel à tous ceux
qui viendraient me dire que il n'y a pas
de question qui se pose surtout avec
l'effondrement du prix des matières
premières et la dépendance de ce grand
pays
aux énergies fossiles alors pour
simplifier les choses nous sommes nous
en Europe confrontés à la menace ce que
j'appelleraiis un étranglement
stratégique à l'inflation du supplice in
qui aurait imaginé en effet il y a 5 ans
qu'un État comme la Syrie se décompose
sous les effets d'une guerre civile et
qu'on son peuple entier plus de 20
millions d'habitants soit jeté sur les
routes on parle de la
Syrie qui imaginait qu'un mouvement
terroriste barbare il cherchent les
formes d'un état et prennent racine
faute de quoi faute de la moindre
détermination de la communauté
internationale qui a laissé
faire qui pouvait imaginer que l'Union
européenne un des garants de la paix en
Europe soit
elle-même menacé dans ses fondements
sous la triple menace d'une crise d'une
explosion migratoire alors là absolument
sans précédent tout le monde parle des
changements climatiques la terre n'a
connu que des changements climatiques la
terre n'a jamais connu une explosion
migratoire comme celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui quiit d'ailleurs
une explosion démographique qui va nous
faire passer d'ici à 2100 de 7 milliards
d'habitants à 11 milliards et demi là il
y a un phénomène sans précédent une
crise
financière j'y reviendrai la semaine
prochaine qui nous amène on se demande
bien pourquoi faire appel au
FMI je me demande quelle est la
légitimité du FMI à intervenir dans une
crise financière entre États européens
on aura l'occasion d'en parler pour la
convention Europe et
enfin la mise en cause par un de ses
membres essentiels je veux dire le
Royaume-Uni de son appartenance à
l'Union nous par parons bien de la deuxè
économie d'Europe on parle pas de la
Grèce on parle pas de Malte on parle pas
de
Chypre qui aurait imaginé qu'un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité m
permanent la la
Russie se trouve à occuper on peut
discuter jusqu'à saciété du contexte
mais une partie du territoire ses
voisins vous savez l'attachement que
j'ai à la
Russie se trouve quand même dans cette
situation là sans que d'ailleurs
absolument personne n réagit sur le
moment on a eu ce grand moment où
François Hollande a expliqué à la
télévision que il avait des contacts
indirects avec Vladimir
Poutine enfin qui aurait
imaginé et vous connaissez mon souci de
l'Alliance atlantique mais qui aura
imaginé que les États-Unis
la première puissance militaire du monde
renonce en Syrie à exercer leur
responsabilité face un emploi d'armes
chimique j'avais cru comprendre mais
sans doute me suis-je trompé qu'il y
avait une ligne rouge qui avait été
déterminé la ligne rouge a été black
Boué avec une violence inouie je n'ai vu
aucune réaction particulière voilà ce
monde ce n'est pas le monde dont nous
avons rêvé mais c'est le monde qui se
trouve devant nous alors cette situation
se traduit par une croissance des
budgets de défense dans nombreux pays il
y a quand même cette information que
nous devons porter à la connaissance de
nos
compatriotes le budget allemand de la
Défense dépasse en 2016 celui de la
France c'est un chiffre qui a été caché
c'est un chiffre qui a été masqué c'est
un chiffre dont nous avons voulu que
vous le
connaissiez parce que cela en dit
long sur l'absence
d'ambition du gouvernement
français car naturellement l'Allemagne
avec 34 milliards d'euros nous avec
32 à ma connaissance le niveau
d'engagement des Allemands n'a rien à
voir avec celui des Français
et à ma connaissance l'Allemagne n'a pas
l'arme nucléaire de
surcroix je crois que c'est sans
précédent depuis bien longemps et c'est
un fait et à ceux qui viendrai nous
reprocher de trop grandes ambitions pour
la défense nationale française je les
renvoie à consulter le budget de nos
partenaires allemands souvent présenté
comme extrêmement vertueux la question
que nous posons nous les républicains
est-ce que les Français avec un membre
permanent avec qu'un statut deande
permanent du Conseil de sécurité avec
l'arme atomique dans ces deux
composantes peuvent se permettre d'avoir
un budget de la défense inférieur à
celui des Allemands c'est un sujet
politique stratégique absolument majeur
et à ceux qui me font le reproche d'une
trop grande ambition je les renvoie à
cette comparaison et qui me soit permis
de dire avec tout l'amour que j'ai pour
mon pays que ça en Dison sur le risque
de décrochage
qui est le nôtre car c'est bien de cela
dont il s'agit alors utile de rappeler
que l'addition de tous les budget de
défense européen
réuni ça reste un
par rapport à celui des
États-Unis alors nous avons pu critiquer
moi-même l'inaction du président Obama
en Syrie mais soyons honnête quelle
crédibilité reste aux
européens où est notre leadership
politique où est l'expression de notre
vol
financière économique dans ces enjeux
stratégiques majeurs à ma connaissance
la Syrie c'est la Méditerranée la
Méditerranée c'est
l'Europe donc on peut débattre à
l'infini fallait-il intervenir en
Afghanistan fallait-il intervenir au
cowet ça vait-il intervenir faut-il
intervenir en Irak il y a un débat que
vous ne pouvez pas évacuer c'est que la
question de l'intervention en Libye en
Syrie ou de l'aide à la Tunisie ne se
pose pas parce que c'est le l'Europe et
c'est la
France on ne peut pas faire comme si
nous nous avions l'Atlantique entre
notre pays et la ligne de front la
sécurité en Méditerranée c'est d'abord
la question des Européens à moins que
les Européens renonc à toute ambition en
la matière alors en Europe il n'y a que
la France et le
Royaume-Uni qui
conserve une ambition
minimum et il faut maintenant regarder
les choses en face qu'ous à faire pour
les 5 ans qui viennent la situation
aujourd'hui de la défense se
caractéristique par deux mots embolie
financière il y a pas besoin
d'ergotter nous devons être mesurés dans
nos constats mais voir la vérité les
opérations militaires ont été menées
avec un grand
professionnalisme on ne dira jamais
assez combien nos militaires ont été
professionnels
mais les contraintes sur les troupes sur
le matériel font peser des risques sans
précédent alors Olivier j'ai entendu ce
que tu as dit
sur
sentinelle sentinelle c'est 100000
hommes ça veut dire qu'avec ctinelle il
y a 70 % de l'armée de terre qui est
inutilisable pour quel COPEX que cela
soit au début 2017 moi si vous savez si
on veut dire que les militaires doivent
faire des opérations de police c'est
qu'on ne comprend rien à ce qu'est un
militaire pour les opérations de police
il y a la
gendarmerieitaire il y a la police et si
on manque d'effectif il y a la réserve
nos soldats ne sont pas adaptés pour
faire des opérations de police vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire par
opération de police mais je dirais
Olivier comme Philippe y compris sur un
territoire extérieur
nos soldats sont là pour défendre les
intérêts stratégiques de la France
protéger nos compatriotes à l'extérieur
et être engagé sur un théâtre de
guerre je je je mets en garde sur la
présence de soldats dans des lieux
public dans le cadre de l'opération
sentinelle au cas où ils seraient
eux-mêmes agressés qu' viendrait à leur
prendre leurs armes où il seraient
amenés à faire utilisation de leurs
armes et je je je veux le dire parce que
je crois la compétence de nos armées je
respecte le professionnalisme de nos
soldats mais dans un état de droit on
utilise chaque force pour ce qu'elle est
censé faire pas en situation de
complément de ce qu'elle n'est pas censé
faire et je le dis cette situation est
insoutenable
alors la le côté ératique de la gestion
depuis 2012 est effrayant en bref on
explique à nos armées qu'il faut baisser
les
effectifs jusqu'en 2015 et là en 2015 on
nous explique qu'il faut les
augmenter naturellement en payant la
facture à partir de
2017 doit pas être très optimiste sur sa
situation en
2017 alors je crois par ailleurs qu'il
nous faut repenser nos OPEX et je veux
le dire très
clairement les OPEC ne peuvent pas être
la réponse unique et j'ajoute solitaire
de la France à toutes les crises
internationales ni le vecteur d'un
engagement
indéfini de notre pays pour des missions
de police
internationale l'engagement ne peut pas
être
indéfini il y a des OPEX où nous sommes
là-bas depuis plus de 30
ans il y a
oui je veux redire mon attachement au
Liban à sa souveraineté et au fait que
la France n'abandonnera jamais le
Liban ENF aux Nations Unies il y a 199
pays je me demande si c'est la vocation
de la
France d'être
seul plus de 30 ans pour une opération
d'opeex je veux rappeler que la France
n'est pas là pour occuper un pays il est
là pour intervenir soit pour défendre
ses intérêts stratégiques soit sous
mandat et ça pose un problème je vous
parler très franchement et nous avance
devir de vérité en
Centre-Afrique je croyais qu'on devait
intervenir quelques semaines ou quelques
mois peut-on m'expliquer ce que nous y
faisons et combien de temps nous allons
rester est-ce le rôle de l'armée
française de séparer en en centraafrique
des musulmans et des chrétiens
sommes-nous les mieux adaptés pour ça
est-ce le rôle des soldats de faire ça
qu'on comprenne bien qu'on doivent
intervenir parce que il y avait un
risque de génocide je je peux le
comprendre et d'ailleurs n'étant pas au
pouvoir je n'ai sans doute pas eu tous
les éléments pour
décider mais je me souviens de ce qui
s'est passé au Rwanda et des polémiques
qui ont succédé et du mal que ça a
fait est-on sûr qu'on doit intervenir
dans le cadre d'une guerre civile y
a-t-il une organisation
AF non la France ne peut pas seule agir
en permanence tiraillé entre le reproche
d'être une puissance coloniale qui n'a
pas tourné la
page et faire jouer à nos soldats dans
un casextrêmement
polémique un rôle pour lequel ils ne
sont pas adaptés les forces françaises
au
Mali je peux comprendre qu'au moment où
des colonnes descendaient sur
bamaco et qu'il n'y avait pas de
gouvernement malien stabilisé à l'époque
on est décidé l'intervention mais enfin
j'aimerais là aussi qu'on explique au
français le Sahel c'est un territoire
grand comme trois fois la
France montagne
désert grotte on y envoie 3000
hommes
seul quelle est la mission exactement
qu'on leur
fixe tenir à 3000 un territoire grand
comme trois fois la
France que nous aidions le Mali grand
pays qui fut même un empire pays que
j'aime
énormément je peux parfaitement le
comprendre pourquoi seul sommes-nous les
seuls en Europe intéressés par la
stabilité la sécurité au Sahel est-on
incapable
maintenant de créer les conditions d'une
coalition lorsque la éta sous la botte
de kadfi qui menaçait de faire couler
des rivières de sang s à
Bengazi j'ai pris président de la
République la responsabilité de
constituer une vaste coalition avec des
partenaires européens lesquels les
anglais David Cameron a été un homme
courageux avec des pays arabes qui
étaient avec nous parce que j'avais
clairement dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de
soldat français au sol et donc il
fallait bien des soldats de nation
arabes pour faire le travail mais
n'est-on plus en mesure de rassembler
une coalition autour de nous il y avait
personne qui était d'accord avec nous on
doit porter tout seul ce poids-là pardon
de le dire ce n'est pas raisonnable je
crois des
OPEX de guerre entre
guillemets limité dans le
temps nous sommes restés 10 ans à
l'époque de bacbo en Côte d'Ivoire
étaitce notre place pour y faire
quoi j'ai utilisé l'armée française
c'est vrai ce mandat des Nations Unies
lorsque le président Ouara était élu
démocratiquement reconnu par la
communauté
internationale qui nous a demandé
d'intervenir le président Ouattara grand
président s'il en est a été mis après
les élections à sa place
puis nous sommes partis nous avons des
forces encore là-bas mais en nombre très
beaucoup plus faible et qui n'ont
absolument pas vocation à séparer nos
amis Ivoiriens qui soi musulmans du Nord
comme le président Ouara ou chrétien ça
un
sens j'ajoute que heureusement je le dis
au militaires qui sont dans la salle que
nous avons pris la responsabilité en
2008 d'ouvrir la base d'Abu
Dhabi grande polémique à l'époque
Philippe tu t'en souvient aujourd'hui
qu'il conteste l'utilité de la base
première base ouverte depuis le
lendemain de la guerre qui conteste bon
parce que j'ai considéré à l'époque
pardon de le dire qu'il vaut mieux
mettre une base française chez nos
alliés sur le Golf Persique ou une
partie du destin du monde se jouit
plutôt que de laisser des bases
dissiminer en Afrique nous avons besoin
de soldats pour défendre les intérêts de
nos compatries en cas de crise mais nous
ne sommes pas une force d'occupation et
nous n'avons pas vocation à faire des
opérations de police pour séparer les
belligérant donc ce que je dis sur le
plan international je dis aussi sur le
plan national l'armée c'est l'armée et
l'armée ne fait pas de police alors la
vêusé des matériels et des
infrastructures at un niveau critique il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont la
France consomme son capital militaire et
au rythme actuel notre capital militaire
est menacé d'extinction à l'horizon
2020 il y a une véritable spirale
d'attrition de nos moyens il va falloir
qu'on réfléchisse Philippe sur
l'indisponibilité des équipements sur la
professionnalisation de leur entretien
et puis sans doute sur un meilleur
partenariat avec les fournisseur de
l'armée il y a me semble-t-il énormément
de choses à faire je vous veut également
parler d'un sujet dont on parle jamais
c'est les conditions d'hébergement des
militaires français et leur conditions
militaires qui ne absolument pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'on est en droit
d'exiger et je voudrais que les crédits
affectés à l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine puisse être utilisé
aussi pour l'amélioration des conditions
d'hébergement des soldats et de leur
famille je ne vois pas au nom de quoi ça
serait moins utile de rénover des
bâtiments de nos militaires plutôt que
de les consacrer uniquement à certains
de nos
quartiers je je ça dépense pas un
centime de plus mais me semble-t-il ça
peut participer d'un effort très
important alors maintenant venons-en au
budget j'ai été chef des
armées tous les parlementaires ici
présents sont passionnés des questions
de défense et l'affirmation de principe
politique je souhaiterais que vous
reteniez ce matin c'est que nous les
républicains nous pensons que la nation
doit consentir un effort renouvelé à
l'endroit de notre appareil de défense
et nos
militaires j'avais dit que les
ministères de sécurité seraient exonéré
vous en souvenez de tout effort de
réduction des dépenses publiques et des
effectifs que nous faisons pour les
autres donc dès 2017 nous passerons une
revue stratégique et je le dis envoyant
mon ami Gérard Longuet moi je ne veux
plus me livrer à l'exercice du Livre
blanc d'une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire parce que j'en
ai tellement connu pardon ça fait un peu
vieux mais
enfin ministre du Budget en 1993 j'en ai
vu passer hein bon donc pour moi c'est
clair je veux une revue stratégique et
des engagement pris sur 5 ans car les
engagements qu'on peut tenir c'est les
engagements sur un
quinquena naturellement je dirais 6 ans
si cétait 6 ans ou un septena c'était un
septena mais vis-à-vis des militaires
nous prenons des engagements sur 5 ans
c'est pas la peine de prendre des
engagements sur 20 ans parce que les
électeurs étant ce qu'ils sont il n'est
pas évident que tout ceci dure autant
qu'on ne pourrait euh l'imaginer bon
c'est une certaine expérien qui me
permet de de le
dire je je voudrais d'ailleurs de ce
point de vue faire un affirmer un
deuxième choix qui je sais qu' n'est pas
consensuel mais il est très important à
mes
yeux la France
est le pays qui dispose d'une dissuision
nucléaire
autonome je veux dire sans blesser nos
amis anglais dont on connaît les liens
avec les Américains que nous sommes le
sol pay je n'accepterai jamais que nous
renoncions au feu nucléaire au service
de la France
jamais ce n'est pas un sujet de disc que
les choses soient claires sur des
affaires de cette importance stratégique
il ne peut pas y avoir
d'ambigué c'est trop grave c'est trop
lourd alors pour le coup c'est pas une
affaire de 5
ans la France est membre permanent du
Conseil de sécurité
la France a un rôle
essentiel sur la scène
internationale
supprimer la composante nucléaire c'est
déclasser la France et pour moi il y a
deux
composant il y a la sous-marine et il y
a l'aéroporté et nous n'avons pas
choisir entre les deux nous devons
garder les deux parce que les deux
correspondent à des orientations
stratégiques qui ne sont pas les
je dirais que la sous-marine corresponde
à des intérêts absolument vitaux qui
permettrai dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
de dire à quelque agresseur que cela
soit que s'il devait toucher à
l'intégrité de la France nous serions
capable
d'exterminer quelqu'un qui voudrait
exterminer la France c'est pas rien et
la composante aéroportée obéit à
d'autres logiques j'ai déjà été trop
long je ne veux pas rentrer làdessus
mais je je je veux que ça soit clair ce
n'est pas un sujet de débat pour nous
c'est une question de conviction et là
il ne peut pas y avoir de compromis ou
de justes mesures ce qui veut dire que
nous intégrons dans l'effort de défense
n'est-ce pas Philippe n'est-ce pas Yve
n'est-ce pas Olivier les 2 milliards
annuels supplémentaires à partir de
2021 parce que quitte à avoir le feu
nucléaire temps de faire qui soit
dissuasif et qu'il a un minimum de
crédibilité sur le budget par ailleurs
je ne reviendrai pas sur ce qu'on fait
les socialistes pour nous voici les
engagements que nous
prenons nous prévoyons de porter le
budget de la défense à 1,85 % du PIB
c'est 1,5 % aujourd'hui et pour faire
plaisir à mon ami Philippe qui j'ai bien
expliqué ça ça veut dire 35 milliards en
2018 41 en 2022 hors pension en euro
constant enfin ça fait 32 milliards
d'euros cumulés de plus je
rappelle qu'en
1990 le budget de la défense était 39
milliards
d'euros donc avec ça on retrouve le
niveau de 1990 non mais j'ai je veux que
ça soit clair parce que il faut pas se
raconter d'
dans dans tout ça je j'ai parlé du
budget allemand je veux parler de
l'histoire des budgets de la Défense
français notre objectif c'est 2 % du PIB
2025 hors pension ce sont des
engagements
sérieux crédiiblees c'est ça où le
déclassement de la France et je ne vois
pas comment nous pourrions nous les
républicains dire aux Français vous êtes
menacé comme jamais vous n'avez été
menacé
et dans le même temps ne pas prendre les
engagements qui sont les nôtres et je le
dis parlant sous contrôle d' pour moi il
y a un continuum entre les forces de
sécurité intérieure les forces de
sécurité extérieure un mot sur l'Europe
de la défense j'aimerais qu'on arrête
avec ça d'abord mes chers
amis un pays qui ne veut pas se défendre
lui-même c'est un pays qui sera pas
défendu par les autres
et ça que les choses soient très
claires bien sûr je vois agiter le
concept d'Europe de la défense moins ça
marche plus on
l'agite mes chers
amis c'est les Français qui doivent
défendre la France d'abord ça c'est une
politique et qui doivent se donner les
moyens de défendre leur patrie ça c'est
une politique deuxièmement qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire Europe de la défense on va
mettre le feu nucléaire à la discussion
en Europe c'estd qu'on va convoquer de
présent de préférence un jour
ouvrable les 27 autres chefs d'État on
va débattre jusqu'à 3h du du matin on ne
délègue pas sa
sécurité je crois à des coopérations
comme nous l'avions fait avec Lancaster
House je crois à la création d'un G3
avec l'Angleterre et l'Allemagne pour
développer un certain nombre d'ARM
je crois la coopération industrielle
cher Christophe
Airbus tout ce qu'on peut faire on a des
industriels de l'armement remarquable et
un délégué général à l'armement
remarquable aussi le pauvre en disant ça
je vais lui faire des ennuis mais
enfin tenez il reste un
an mais je ne crois pas que l'on puisse
justifier une diminution du budget de
défense française
au prétexte d'une politique de défense
europé on va dire oui mais regardez tous
les pays d'Europe de l'Est augmentent
leur budget de défense Ceres c'est vrai
mais pourquoi pour la
Russie je ne suis pas sûr que ça
corresponde absolument aux intérêts
stratégiques qui sont les nôtres et a la
politique étrangère que nous allons
mener donc
oui a de la coopération oui a du
bilatéral voire du trilatéral oui a des
projets industriels
commun mais la défense d'un pays c'est
les citoyens de ce pays qui l'amène
alors un mot pour terminer chè Marianne
et cher Olivier sur le lien armée nation
d'abord peut-être une anecdote mais
j'aimerais tellement qu'on revoit dans
nos territoires des manœuvres des armées
françaises quand j'étais jeune on voyait
cela très souvent et c'était très bien
pour le moral des armées et pour le la
la le R rochement entre la population et
les armées je pense que c'est une très
bonne idée que les soldats sortent de
leur caserne et qu' fassent entraînement
aussi sur le territoire national mais
notre idée est la suivante j'en ai parlé
d'ailleurs avec les plus hautes
autorités militaires de notre pays la
France est confrontée à un problème de
décrocheur formidable Marianne Olivier
le savent bien chaque année il y a
100000 jeunes qui sortent des radars qui
vont plus ou moins l'école cheer réque
depuis la 3è plutôt moins que
plus et qu'on voit réapparaîte au moment
du
hémi notre idée est la suivante c'est
100000 décrocheur à l'âge de 18 ans nous
leur indiquerons la chose suivante
avez-vous un emploi si vous avez un
emploi pas de problème suivez-vous une
formation qualifiante si vous suivez une
formation qualifiante pas de problème
vous n'avez pas d'emploi vous n'avez pas
de formation service militaire
obligatoire voilà ce que nous proposons
cela veut dire
réaccoutumer ces jeunes à la règle je
Levis tô le
matin à l'effort physique à
l'obéissance à l'apprentissage d'un
certain nombre de permis de conduire y
compris poids lourd peut-être même à
l'apprentissage du
et même et même d'une autre
langue ça sera financé je ne sais pas
est-ce que ça sera 50000 est-ce que ça
sera 40000 est-ce que ça soit 60000 je
ne sais pas sur le budget de l'Éducation
nationale puisque c'est un encadrement
militaire mais naturellement c'est une
tâche de
l'éducation nationale le service
militaire adapté est une réussite
absolument remarquable remè qui n'a
jamais visité cher Gérard un service
militaire adapté ne sait pas ce qu'il en
est et peut-être ne le savez-vous pas 65
% des jeunes qui sont en service
militaire
adapté
outre sont des jeunes qui ont des
difficultés sociale
comportementale culturelle du langage
extrêmement profonde l'encadrement
militaire est le seul à même de prendre
en charge ces jeunes et ça nous
permettrait de rapprocher encore un peu
plus la nation de nos militaires enfin
Olivier a parlé des anciens combattants
pour moi c'est pas un sujet de
plaisanterie j'ai voulu d'ailleurs être
à la cérémonie du 8 mai parce que vous
savez j'ai longtemps
pensé qu'une civilisation se
reconnaissait à la façon dont elle
traitait ces personnes
âgées parce que aussi cuux que ça puisse
paraître si tout se passe bien on sera
tous un jour
âgé si tout se passe bien et donc la
façon dont on traite les personnes âgées
en don sur la conception que l'on porte
de l'homme de l'être humain si on est un
humaniste ou pas et bien la façon dont
on traite les anciens combattants c'est
la façon dont on considère l'histoire de
son pays quand on méprise l'histoire de
son pays on est incapable de parler de
l'avenir de son pays respecter les
anciens combattant et respecter
l'histoire de notre pays le devoir de
mémoire c'est un devoir essentiel alors
Olivier je sais parfaitement que ça fait
sourire en général c'est ceux qui n'y
comprennent rien qui par les temps qui
courent sont assez légion faut bien dire
l'histoire du secrétariat d'État moi ça
me fait pas sourire
parce que les gens dont on parle c'est
des gens qui sont morts qui sont
estropiés qui sont blessés pour vous
défendre pour nous défendre quand on va
à Persie et j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce
que tu as dit sur les combattants
d'aujourd'hui et tu vois ces jeunes
défigurés marchant avec des prothèses cl
sur un
lit ça fait plus rire à
jamais cette question ne fait sourire
que ceux qui on vu un blessé que ceux
qui ont jamais su ce que c'était que
dire père et mère d'un gamin de 22 ans
qui est mort au théâtre de combat parce
que vous avez pris une décision votre
fils ne reviendra pas moi ça ne me fait
pas rire et donc je veux réaffirmer
l'engagement que tu as pris parce qu'au
fond mais c'est une
dette c'est une dette une dette de la
nation et je veux d'ailleurs dire que
dans cette dette nous devons prendre
notre histoire dans son ensemble y
compris quand la France n'a pas été
formidable je pense au
arquy qui ont été victime de leur
attachement de leur fidélité à la
France et dire
cela c'est important vous savez il m'est
arrivé de décorer des
militaires c'était ma d'illeurs ma
fierté dont les décorations avaient
portter à un peu de polémique de grands
soldats mais moi je prends l'histoire de
France telle qu'elle
est vous savez que je n'ai connu qu'une
seule famille politique la famille
Gauliste mais ça ne m'empêche pas
d'avoir décoré des militaires qui s'étit
opposé à un moment donné au général de
Gaulle parce que j'ai pensé que
l'histoire de la France était une qu'on
la divisait pas et qu' avait des gens
qui s'étaient comportés avec loyauté
dans des conditions extraordinairement
comp complexe qui sont celles quand une
histoire
familiale vient contre-choquer une
histoire collective notre pays est un
grand pays il a connu des grands
événements et nous nous devons les
reconnaître comme tels et donc pour moi
la mémoire des anciens combattants et
l'effort qu'on doit faire pour eux ça
compte j'ajoute qu'un budgetaire averti
doit comprendre que comme la vie est la
vie les anciens combattants sont de
moins en moins nombreux c'est peut-être
le seul domaine où on peut augmenter
tout en diminuant la somme globale si on
veut bien réfléchir ben oui pour des
raisons vous savez malheureusement qui
vont qui vont absolument tous nous
toucher un jour mesdames et mieurs j'en
aais terminé en remerciant encore mes
amis je veux que vous compreniez que ces
engagements que nous prenons nous les
avons pris par écrit et tu comprends
Gérard tu comprends Christophe pourquoi
j'ai voulu que les républicains
politique les primaires c'est bien
l'engagement collectif ça compte aussi
ce que vous avez fait ce que vous avez
écrit c'est l'engagement politique de
toute une famille je vous
remercie